okay ready for part three of this vision
of linear algebra so the key word in
part three is orthogonal which again
means perpendicular so we have
perpendicular vectors we can imagine
those we have something called
orthogonal matrices that's when I've got
one here orthogonal matrix is when we
have these columns I I'm always going to
use the letter Q for an orthogonal
matrix and I look at its columns and
every column is perpendicular to every
other column so I have a so I just don't
just have two perpendicular vectors
going like this I have n of them because
I'm in n dimensions and you just imagine
XYZ axes or XYZ w axes go up to four D
for relativity go up to eight D for
spring theory eight dimensions
oh we just have vectors after all it's
just this row of numbers or a column of
numbers and we can decide when when
things are perpendicular by that test
like say the test for Q 1 to be
perpendicular to Q n is that row times
that column when I say times I mean dot
product multiplied every pair Q 1
transpose Q and gives that 0 up there so
the columns are perpendicular and those
matrices are the best to compute with
and again they're called Q and one way
to do a quick matrix way because there's
always a matrix way to to explain
something and you just you'll see how
quick it is here this business of having
columns that are perpendicular to each
other and actually I'm gonna make those
lengths of all those column vectors all
one just to sort of normalize it then
Express all that's expressed by if I
multiply Q transpose by Q I'm taking all
the
dot products and I'm getting ones when
it's Q against itself and I'm getting
zeroes when it's one Q versus another Q
and again just think of three
perpendicular axes those are the those
directions are the Q 1 Q 2 Q 3 ok so we
really want to compute with those here's
an example well that has just two
perpendicular axes I didn't have space
for the third one so so do you see that
that those two columns are perpendicular
again what does that mean I take the dot
product - 1 x - 2 - x - 1 and another -
2 so I'm up to minus 4 at this point and
then 2 times 2 gives a plus 4 so it all
washes out to 0 and why is that 1/3
there why is that that's so that these
vectors will have length 1 there will be
unit vectors yeah and how do I figure
the length of a vector well just while
we're at it I take 1 squared or minus 1
squared gives me 1 2 squared + 2 squared
I take the dot product with itself so
minus 1 squared 2 squared + 2 squared
that adds up to 9 the square root of 9
is the length I'm just doing Pythagoras
here there's one side of a triangle
here's a second side of a triangle it's
a right triangle because that vector is
perpendicular to that one it's in 3d
because they have three components and I
didn't write the third a third direction
and their length one vectors because
just that's how we when I compute the
length and remember about the 1/3 which
is put in there to give length 1 so okay
so these matrices are with Q transpose
times Q equal I that again that's the
matrix shorthand for all I've just said
and those matrices are the best because
they don't change the length of anything
you don't have blowup you don't have
going to zero you can multiply together
a thousand matrices and you'll still
have another orthogonal matrix yes
little family of beautiful matrices okay
and very very useful big okay oh and
there is a good example oh I think way I
got that at that example I just added
the third row the third column third
column so 2 squared plus 2 squared plus
-1 squared that adds up to 9 when I take
the square root I get 3 so that has
length 3 I divided by 3 so it would have
length 1 we always want to see ones like
we do there and if I here's a simple
fact but great that if I have 2 of these
matrices or 50 of these matrices I could
multiply them together and I would still
have length 1 I'd still have orthogonal
matrices 1 times 1 times 1 forever is 1
ok so it's probably something hiding
here oh yeah oh yeah to understand why
these matrices are important this one is
this line is telling me that if I have a
vector X and I multiply by Q it doesn't
change the length this is a symbol for
length squared and that's equal to the
original length squared length is
preserved by these Q's everything is
preserved you're multiplying effectively
by the matrix versions of 1 and minus 1
so and a rotation is a very significant
very valuable orthogonal matrix which
just has cosines and sines and
everybody's remembering that cosine
squared plus sine squared is 1 from trig
and that's oh that's a that's a a an
orthogonal matrix
oh it's also orthogonal because the dot
product between that one and that one
you're okay for the dot product that
that product gives me minus sine cosine
plus sine cosine 0 so the column 1 is
orthogonal to call
- that's good okay these lambdas that
you see here are something called
eigenvalues that's not allowed until the
next lecture okay all right now here's
something here's a computing thing if we
have a bunch of columns not orthogonal
not length 1 then we often we would like
to convert them to so call those a 1 to
a n nothing special about those columns
we would like to convert them to
orthogonal columns because they are the
beautiful ones q1 up to QN and two guys
called Graham and schmidt figured out a
way to do that and a century later we're
still using their idea well I don't know
whose idea was actually I think Graham
had the idea and I'm not really sure
what Schmidt how he got into it well he
may have repeated the idea so okay so it
just I won't go all the details but
here's what the point is the point is if
I have a bunch of columns that are
independent they go in different
directions but they're not 90-degree
directions then I can convert it to a
90-degree one to two perpendicular axes
with a matrix that a matrix R happens to
be triangular that did the did the
moving around did take the combinations
so a equal QR is one of the fundamental
steps of linear algebra and
computational linear algebra very very
often we're given a matrix a we want a
nice matrix Q so we do this gram-schmidt
step 2 makes a columns orthogonal and oh
there's the first step of gram-schmidt
but you need practice for the for the to
see all the steps maybe not
okay so here
what's the advantage of perpendicular
vectors suppose I have a triangle and
one side is perpendicular to the second
side what how does that help well that's
a that's a right triangle then side a
perpendicular side B and of course
Pythagoras
now we're really going back Pythagoras
said that a squared plus B squared is C
squared so we have beautiful formulas
when things are perpendicular if I if
the angles are not 90 degrees when the
cosine of 90 degrees is 1 or maybe the
sine of 90 degrees is 1 ya sine of 90
degrees is 1 for those perfect angles 0
and 90 degrees where we can do
everything and here's a here's a place
that Q fits just to make it this is like
the first applicant big application of
linear algebra so let me just say what
it is and it uses these cubes so what's
the application it's called least
squares and it's you start with
equations ax equal B you always think of
that as a matrix times the unknown
vector being a known right-hand side B
ax equal B so suppose we have too many
equations that often happens if you take
too many measurements you want to get
something you want to get an exact x so
you do more and more measurement to be
you're pasting more and more conditions
on X and you're not going to find an
exact x because you've got too many
equations M is bigger than n we might
have 2000 measurements say from medical
things or from satellites and we might
have only 2 unknowns fitting a straight
line with only two variables so how am I
going to solve 2,000 equations with two
unknowns well I'm not but I look for the
best solution how close can I come and
that's what least squares is about you
you get
be ax as close as possible to be and
probably this will show how the how the
yeah yeah here's the right equation when
you here's my message when you can't
solve ax equal B multiply both sides by
a transpose then you can solve this
equation that's the right equation so I
put a little hat on that X to show that
it doesn't solve the original equation
ax equal B but it comes the closest it's
the closest solution I could find and it
it's discovered by multiplying both
sides by this a transpose matrix so a
transpose a is a terrifically important
matrix it's a square matrix C a didn't
have to be square I could have lots of
measurements there many many equations
long thin matrix for a but a transpose a
always comes out square and also
symmetric and it's just a great matrix
for a theory and this Q our business
makes it work in practice let me see if
there's more so this is y oh yeah this
is the geometry so I start with a matrix
a it's only got a few columns maybe even
only two columns so it's a column space
it's just a plane not the whole space
but my right-hand side B is somewhere
else in whole space you see this
situation I can only solve ax equal B
when B is in this one B is a combination
of the columns and here it's not the
measurements weren't perfect I'm off
somewhere so I have how do i how do you
deal with that geometry tells you mmm
you can't deal with B it's not you can't
solve ax equal B so you drop a
perpendicular you find the closest point
the projection that in the space where
your can solve so then you solve ax
equal P that's what least squares is all
about fit
the best straight-line the best parabola
whatever is all in your algebra of
perpendicular things and orthogonal
matrices okay I think that's what I what
I can say about orthogonal well it'll
come in again orthogonal matrices
perpendicular columns is so beautiful
but next is coming eigenvectors and
that's a another chapter so I'll stop
here good thanks